there are
bigger things to worry about today and
by the way i'm not telling you you're
not fighting for it i'm not telling you
absolutely
my argument isn't the fact that let's
just set it aside let it happen on all
this other stuff who cares it's not
really a big deal
i'm not talking about that i'm talking
about character assassination
i'm talking about silencing at the
highest level i'm talking about all of
those things being an issue today
where the energy is being put into
somewhere where that weapon is outdated
today
it was necessary 50 years ago but not in
2021 i may be wrong
so i'm kind of talking around something
that i haven't want to delve into
specifically
because the reason why i hesitate on
doing that ironically enough is based
around the very things you're talking
about
because they can take what i'm going to
say flip it and say i'm inciting this
because at the end of the day if it
happens to enough people
and enough people are like i've had
enough of it i've had enough of this
tyranno
of the of this tyrannical government
shutting me down on my platforms in
order to use my first amendment right
shutting me down
my ability to make a living and all of
these things at the end of the day
yes we can collectively come out in the
streets with guns
and make a stand that's something that's
that can be done
so from that perspective you know
so that it happened so that actually did
happen right so let's go to
when the protesting slash
riots happen but it's peaceful
protesting we know it wasn't peaceful
protesting
when the protestant was taking place
this summer during covet
businesses were getting trashed you saw
this 17 year old kids going out there
and just protecting themselves
and defending businesses yeah well you
know the script was flipped and it was
look at these
you know the people who are out there
you know look how they're being raised
and they're going around with guns and
all these peaceful protesting
no one hears the rhetoric that you're
giving all they see is what's being told
on tv and on tv it shows that you are
radical
you are radical nor you're being painted
as a radical individual you are the
radical ones
not all the other folks and then you go
and present yourself in dc
and say hey here's what we're capable of
doing and then you know what comes next
oh inciting all this stuff then you're
turned off you're silenced
now what so all i'm all i'm talking
about
is strategically all i'm talking about
you got money here
right that's being put into different uh
uh issues
gun rights and gun control from 1990
election cycle through december of 2019
gun rights and gun control
interest groups reported the following
political contributions to federal
candidacy
total contribution gun rights 44 million
total
gun uh contribution gun control 9.3
million
donations by democrats 4 million
donations by republicans 39 million but
don't understand
so you look at these numbers you're like
okay money's being invested in certain
areas
democrats quite frankly are not really
putting that much money in gun control
republicans are putting 45 million
democrats are putting only 9 million
republicans are putting five times more
into the gun
issue than democrats are right but what
are democrats quietly doing
they're getting their base and their
voice and their audience to get louder
to control what you can and can't say
the more they do that even a great
argument loses
to one who has more eyeballs don't you
agree yeah
we'll see they can afford to spend less
on the gun issue because they already
have the bullhorn that's right and so
and that's
part of the reason why i try to couch
my discussion under the guise of it's
not a guy as it is
as a as a cultural war because that's
essentially what it is it's a cultural
war against
the ownership of fires because when
people one thing that i will say about
me and my journey with respect to
firearms
the firearm was a catalyst for a lot of
other things for me that were in the
positive
because it was i remember when i first
got my ability to conceal carry i got my
license to conceal carry my firearm
and it was at that moment that i
realized the only person responsible for
my safety is me
that's the person i can't rely on
anybody else it's going to be me
and so that mindset in and of itself
starts to trickle into other aspects of
your life
whether it be business whether it be the
way you handle your relationships
that is a that is a freedom
self-sustaining mindset that
honestly does not bode very well for a
particular group of political class
who base their entire ideology on the
prominence of government
and the dependency on said government
because when you have people who think
from an independent mindset
it's harder to get them to lean and
depend on a bigger government
we have a problem with that it's because
they generate so much of their money so
much of their influence
from having a bigger government well
they're going to do everything in their
power
from a cultural perspective to tell you
how much you don't need those
things they understand what the firearm
does symbolically to a person
and how it changes their mindset in a
manner that is actually positive
contrary to what a lot of people think
who thinks is pretty much for the
negative
and i'm a walking talking example of
that yeah
i mean look we need a hundred of you we
need a thousand of you
one you know we need people that are
putting this argument out there for
others to sit there and say like even
when bill maher talked to you bill maher
was like
he was a little bit more subtle he
wasn't challenging you he wasn't pushing
you
and then you almost sat there and said
well first of all i respect you the
reason the only reason why he wouldn't
push you harder
is probably because he didn't research
the topic enough
to be able to have the data to debate
you so it's like look this is not really
my deal
i just kind of i'm looking at and he
just kind of let you do your part i'm
like
wow even a bill maher who is a guy
that's got strong opinions about
religion about
god about a lot of different things he
himself hasn't done a lot of research
on gun rights and second amendment so if
you like this sort of short club from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye